hey guys my name is Jess it is the 8th
of febri and here's the things that
matters in gaming today after a small
miscommunication and subsequent outrage
Ubisoft have confirmed that the pc
version of the division has not been
held back in order to keep it in check
with consoles during a recent interview
with YouTube channel team epiphany and
unnamed developer unintentionally
insinuated that the pc version was held
back for consoles they said one good
thing about the division is we've always
considered the PC as a separate platform
we do have to keep it in check with the
consoles it would be kind of unfair to
push it so far away from them but it's
been good having a dedicated pc build
for this game once word got out people
freaked and Ubisoft Tom's gamespot's
it's come to our attention that a
comment from one of our team members has
been perceived by some members of the
community to imply the pc version of the
division was held back and this is
simply not true from the beginning the
pc version of the division was developed
from the ground up and we're confident
players will enjoy the game and the
features this version has to offer and
the feedback from PC players who
participated in the recent closed beta
supports this over the weekend a number
of xbox 360 games including red dead
redemption became playable on Xbox one
Microsoft Hobson's explained this was an
error presumably a pretty big error
Microsoft's Major Nelson explained
Microsoft tests all xbox 360 games with
our backwards compatibility emulator to
ensure a quality experience across the
breadth of titles due to an error some
of the games currently in tests were
accidentally made available we have
since removed access to these games and
apologize for any confusion this may
have caused we will have more
information on upcoming releases soon
Microsoft warns that playing the games
they accidentally that life could be a
violation of the xbox code on
but people who downloaded the games
anyway will find they can still play
them while their console is offline that
said red deads game saves reportedly
don't work offline so that's probably
not what you want at least you can rest
assured that microsoft do seem to be
trying to get games like red dead and
left for dead two working with backwards
compatibility and finally today you can
now watch the opening cinematic the Dark
Soul story bandai namco released the
ethics cinematic trailer today which
shows off the wonderfully mccobb
characters and creatures your meat in
the game including young the giant
eldritch saint of the deep and ferens
undead legion it's all pretty bloody
epic and worth checking out in full on
our site if you haven't already dark
souls crater he'd attack in Miyazaki has
said he intends to wrap up the sole
series with his game and hopes to see
from software pursue new ideas Dark
Souls 3 launches on April 12 / ps4 xbox
one and pc let me know down in the
comments if you're particularly keen on
playing red dead redemption on xbox one
you can add your game start with both
stories on the Assassin's Creed movie
and the Hitman beta that is everything
you're happy today thanks for sticking
around as always and I will catch you
again tomorrow